remember when Donald Trump supposedly
saved something like a thousand jobs at
the manufacturing facility of carrier in
Indiana it was touted as this major win
for the economy a major win for Trump
and at the time I told you that this was
not actually what it appeared to be
right this was not economic policy what
Trump did was just give some cash to one
company it's not policy you can't run a
country that way we also learned that
long-term the money that was given by
Trump to carrier wasn't actually going
to save jobs because carriers own
executives admitted that they were going
to use that money to do even more
automation over the medium and long term
they temporarily didn't lay some people
off in exchange for money that they were
going to use to lay people off over the
medium and long term I told you all of
this in July we learned that carrier was
indeed going to do a wave of layoffs in
Indiana and now carrier is doing another
wave of layoffs in Indiana and they are
laying off these employees because
they're hiring 500 people in Mexico for
less money the new yorker did a piece on
this where they actually interview
employees who were being laid off and
for the most part they believed that
Trump had saved them they believed that
Trump had saved their jobs back during
that big showboating announcement that
Donald Trump and Mike Pence did and of
course the Trump administration will say
still well 500 are going to Mexico but
there are hundreds that are staying in
Indiana that's true but those are mostly
the administrative and office jobs not
the manufacturing jobs the office jobs
were never in jeopardy of being moved to
Mexico it was always the manufacturing
jobs that we were talking about and one
of the really really sad parts of the
article that actually I mean I just
really found it so depressing the
article quotes Dwayne Rs Kovac or Earths
Kovac who's quoted in the article is
saying all Trump has to do is sign an
executive order so our jobs don't go
across the borders or across the seas
just sign the piece of paper it's either
a yes he'll do it or a no he won't
and it's really sad to me that folks
think it's that simple
it's really sad to me that people who
believe in the free market and and who
would in normal circumstances say we
shouldn't depend on presidential decrees
we don't want the executive orders are
now saying Trump should just sign an
executive order and save our jobs in
direct contradiction to what the free
market the open market the unregulated
market would dictate which is reduce
costs by sending jobs elsewhere and
develop technology to get rid of those
jobs altogether and replace them with
machines none of this is actually
surprising but it is really really
depressing it's not shocking that the
guy who lies about everything and has
built a career on swindling people maybe
wasn't being upfront about his
miraculous and heroic saving of Indiana
jobs Trump gave cash to one company to
keep some of their jobs in Indiana a
little bit longer at the time he got a
hero's welcome to Indiana
he gained political capital and now
everybody's forgotten about it half of
those jobs saved are disappearing and
people have moved on but the people who
lost their jobs now rather than 12
months ago are still getting screwed
it took 12 months but they got screwed
in the in the long run will they vote
Republican again in the fall I believe
that most of them will I believe that
the statistics which overwhelmingly show
that people vote down the party line and
that most people in Indiana are
Republicans I believe that although
Trump will lose some support in Indiana
because of the lie that he had saved
those jobs I do not even believe for a
second that in any meaningful way Donald
Trump or even Republicans are going to
suffer the consequences of the fact that
it was all a lie the jobs were never
really saved and the money they got was
to automate away the jobs and then
that's why when I go back and I'd read
an article like this and I see that
Dwayne RS Kovach who's losing his job
says just just signed the executive
order it's really really depressing and
I don't care that a lot of the jobs
saved they're Republican jobs this is
absolute
disgusting and it is taking advantage of
people